you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club players from nine
nations converge in st. Louis as us
chess champs calm presents the second
annual summer chess classic hello and
welcome back to the summer chess classic
here in st. Louis
we're very exciting here today very
exciting day here today as always we're
your hosts I'm Caleb Denby I'm joined by
GM Jessie cry and today is round eight
of the summer chess classic of course
there are ten rounds in this event so
we're entering the home stretch of this
event the standings near the top are
getting very very close they've still
been tight throughout the tournament so
we're looking forward to see the players
you know fight their hardest to try and
make it to the number one spot why don't
we actually take a look at the standings
currently in Group A Liam Lee won his
last round game putting him in it's high
for the lead with David Howell and a
plus-one score Geoffrey Zhang
unfortunately lost his leading position
by losing his game to liam Lee so now he
trails by half point along with Sam
Jenkins Gawain Jones and daro spirits
rounds out the group with two and a half
points and over in Group B Gregorio
proned
maintains his lead with another win in
the last round he's a full point of head
of Havana's kuboos Ian who is at 4
points seria Ganguly used to be up near
the top but now he's in the middle of
the pack after a rough couple of rounds
at three and a half points he is joined
with Sam 7 also at three and a half both
of them on an even score Daniel Freedman
and Igor Kovalenko round out the group
with two and a half points over in Group
C we have our turfs Naik saans another
very impressive showing from him with
five points out of seven rounds Dmitry
Gordievsky seems to be the only man
capable of catching him at this point
with four and a half al Shaun morontia
body in Aramco Cobian are both having
very decent tournaments with a level
score and Brandon Jacobson
unfortunately has fallen 2-1 despite
starting out with an early lead in this
event
Kirsten trilha continues his rather
unfortunate tournament only with one and
a half points out of the seven so let's
take a look and see what kind of format
this tournament is for the players there
are three six player in double
round-robin so those are those three
groups we just took a look at of course
everyone plays everyone twice in the
double round-robin so this being the
latter half of the tournament these
players have all seen each other before
so they already kind of know a little
bit of what to expect the time control
for the event is 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves and after move 40 they
get an extra 30 minutes for the
remainder of the game there's a 30
second increment from move 1 and a 30
move draw rule is in effect so no
drawers before move 30 except by
repetition and the schedule for this
events we are finally after that rest
day it is round 8 today Wednesday so we
just have two more rounds after today of
course those are tomorrow and Friday and
the times there are the start times for
the players the start time for the
broadcast is going to be a little
different so there is of course a big
tournament in Croatia
the leg of the grand chest tour so our
broadcast will be starting a half hour
after that broadcast finishes both
tomorrow and the day after here we see
the tournament hall the players are hard
at work today fighting it out to uh you
know battle battle for those top
positions you can join them by following
along with the games at us chess chance
comm you can join us here on the
commentary in YouTube we'll be keeping
an eye on that YouTube chat if you guys
have any questions and can join us on
Twitter as well using the hashtag summer
chess classic well Jesse any thoughts on
the games today Before we jump into him
the most exciting round so far has been
a lot of exciting rounds but this one
has some very tense moments that we're
about to jump into all right well let's
just look at it then the group a
pairings
we have David Howell playing anslee amly
blows - of course leading the tournament
Gawain Jones is playing against Darras
roots and then our key matchup for the
day is actually between Jeffrey Shaw
and Sam Shanklin both players a half
point out of the lead so they'll
definitely be fighting now as we near
the final rounds to catch up to those
leaders you see the players they're both
kind of locked in concentration
it looks like it's it's Sam's move and
quite a few decisions to make here for
both sides what do you think of this
game Jesse well right it's the critical
moment and I'm the move he's calculating
his Knight takes e5 right now mm-hmm and
a little surprising may be that he's
taken so long to play just because he's
the one who set this madness in motion
when Geoffrey here played f4 first of
all I think black is doing fine in this
position after f4 and Sam now begins
very concrete play d4 you pretty much if
you don't take it blacks beautiful he's
gonna play c5 next so snipin by the way
this one sacrifice maybe later we'll
review the game there were several
moments where this pawn sacrifice could
have happened and the positional notion
is that but you're taking the e4 pawn
kind of out of the game by bypassing him
but this more than just a positional
notion now because Bishop e2 rook e1 and
now the night on d2 will be undefended
Sam's got his hand in the air yeah now
he was hovering over his piece and all
you just play rook takes a three Queen
rather Queen takes a swing takes a
different pawn rather than e5 and by
putting pressure on the rook we're
preventing room takes e to I wasn't his
original intention because now white at
the very well let me see I was about to
say that white could get out of Dodge
here and maybe that's true like for
example if white plays Knight to c4 it's
hard to imagine that black that white is
in any serious danger mm-hmm so is there
some I guess there's no internet those
with like rook a1 and then there's a
threat on the bishop how does black
respond to that let's ask that question
okay one and I think Queen c5 right so
Sam oh no you're right you're right and
do that yeah I was thinking Queen d3
might be the only option but then I
wasn't so sure about that position
because maybe the white rook can invade
through a7 what we do something like
Queen takes d3 Bishop takes d3 and in
route k7 is that anything to be
concerned about well what what's it like
if you had another move what would your
next move be
I might play rook I might try to evict
that Bishop or I might just play Knight
b3 to a5 and put pressure on the C pawn
maybe put my other rook on c1 and but I
could have to be happy about this
c5 okay well maybe Rick c1 then and I
can try to play Knight c4 okay you're
just just going to push me back yeah I
guess this is fair to say maybe there's
bishop f1 but then I start I already
have to calculate things like c3 and
Bishop takes F 1 and then c3
no I was surprised by Queen a3 maybe
Jeffery was too it's just okay so let me
just try to believe that sure 95 was the
move he wanted to do I think it just
feels that way when you played because
he played Bishop e2 first okay so
obviously Queen e5 rook d2 is beautiful
for black so is there some way to move
the Queen and defend the night and then
both of blacks pieces are hanging like
Queen III that's what he's dreaming
about right so Queen III and arguably we
the argument is we have absolutely
nothing that might be true
I would have to do something fancy like
93 yeah you're giving up a lot though
with these two pieces right well she's a
Queenie - check this is tricky idea
I don't know how tricky it is but it's
uh it's an idea yeah and there's just
things I don't know as well yeah as
white I'd be worried you always have a
draw here though right like King H 1 and
then King G 1 and then right well let's
say black always has the draw that goes
is it because black can go for it now
with Knight takes and Queen takes sure
so my thinking is maybe Sam thinks he
has something to play for here and so he
didn't like maybe the look of Knight
takes c1 or maybe we're missing
something else there's definitely a
pretty tense situation here so what else
is there you can play like I I don't
know I think we need three might be it
else can you do so if we assume that
we're right that this analysis where
black after 93
wait does have maybe some options you
can play rook c3 maybe that looks like
the knight takes a 191 Queen e2 and I
want to say the Knights trap oh my got a
knight thanks G to 962 oh of course
okay so yeah you know it's tough to say
so anyways it I'm sure Sam looked at
this and this Queen takes a three like
yeah like you pointed out there's rook a
1 and Knight c4 and to me as long as
White has some way of you know just
stabilizing the position then the other
position look better right no but maybe
I'm missing something obviously right
okay so we're gonna keep a close eye on
that this game by the way not only for
tournament standings but both of these
guys are vying to be let's call it the
alternate the US and his team and Sam is
fighting to retain 2,700
and Jeffrey for years now has been
struggling to make that last jump into
the 2700 club so this is gonna be an
exciting game going forward yeah Jeffrey
probably if I were in his spot I would
definitely see the same as sort of a of
arrival right Sam's the last kind of
American to make that jump from the 2600
s to the coveted 2700 s so it's a
definitely a big game for Sam yeah why
don't we take a look at what's going on
in Group B sure
let's see those pairings so Dana
Friedman has already drawn his game
against tournament leader Grigory Oberon
kuboos ian is paired against Kovalenko
and then our key matchup of the day is
two of the followers Sam Sabean against
Syria Ganguly Sam the number one seed
going into this event ran into some
trouble yesterday after finally scoring
his first win in round six so we see the
players there with some romantic
lighting but definitely no romance in
this games it's it's cold-blooded stuff
well it's funny yet we have a lecture
here at the club called Romantic era
chess
some people just mean crazy games when
they do their lecture this though would
come into that rubric where this is the
second game Sam has been white against a
winner work and I thought he had a
beautiful position maybe will back it up
just a second so let's see well first
let's introduce it so we have our winner
and here there's many moves Queen g7 or
a3 let's call as the main moves so takes
and this is I wasn't familiar with this
move but I looked it up in the database
has definitely been played when I was
watching the game it's definitely seemed
like anguli didn't know about this move
I think Knight b6 BC six is the most
common move here he took and it's
questionable if that Bishop is actually
well placed on c5 I would have liked to
keep the the pin on
the piano right so Bishop d3 looks
absolutely correct and this way you
you're saying to black I'm holding Queen
g7 over your head
and if you Castle I'm really gonna start
thinking about sacking on h7 like with
Knight g5 so this is a difficult moment
and Queen b6 didn't seem to help because
now Knight h3 with the same ideas but
defending f2 97 White has different
moves here f4 g6 Bishop d2 this looked
great for white Bishop e3 you know it's
a bummer because if white castles and
gets to play Knight a 4 then that's just
nice to steal the dark square Bishop but
that this is like we're losing Tempe and
losing our good Bishop it's tough I
don't think that that dark square Bishop
from white definitely was the most
intimidating piece and in his camp and
that dark square Bishop is always a
great defender for black right and like
I said the bishop on c5 a little funny
and basically Ganguly said well I've got
to get the Bishop off the square for the
knight ok so here we come to let's call
it the tactical phase and black has a
very rough position ganguly plays h6 Sam
says all right G for Bishop d7 and this
I thought was a fascinating position I
was talking to Alejandro Ramirez Geum
Alejandro Ramirez about this and we both
felt like white was better but and
especially because it's unclear what
black is gonna do next very unclear what
he's going to do next
so it moves but unclear how to press the
position there's natural moves like rook
e1 which seem like you've got to still
be better when you play a move like that
maybe even yeah rook e1 something like
that is the natural way because black he
can't castle really either way yeah with
positions like this it's always
interesting to me because from my mind
I'm always thinking about the pawn
breaks I'm thinking about stuff like f5
if there's any way I can make a pawn
break work to open up the position
but uh same found a different way here
right he used instead of the pawns his
night specifically right so he does this
and the threat which will be executed
here is to play Knight f7 and Queen f6
to separate the King from his friends
and black had a couple moves I think
what he did seemed right and we're gonna
look we're gonna kind of roll into the
game continuation now Queen before so
we're putting pressure on f4 Knight f7
takes and so you see the Queen on b4
holds the e7 night now we kick it but
the Queen is centralized and strong snip
here and a very interesting position
because now blacks King has achieved
some level of safety the white knight
isn't necessarily doing that much and
basically it's gonna be hard for the
white pieces to coordinate especially
and especially not to lose the pawn on
f4 so he went back black said I'm just
gonna pin you in the disc ordination is
real 91 Queen f3 rook g1 rook f7 and I
have no idea what's happening now
definitely a creative way to you know
kind of steal the activity from white
there cuz you know usually when you're
sacrificing you're doing it for activity
and to get your pieces near near the
king but in this case they really
managed to take that sacrifice and in
turn gave white the pawn well now black
has all the activity well now he did
your move no Sam said all right it's
time and then Oh certain way he's
whether this is winning or whatever
whatever we decide to say about this f5
move he kind of had to do it because the
f4 pawn was just gonna hang for free if
he didn't so so it's black I mean your
first instinct has to be I want to take
that guy that's trying with the e pawn
and then with the bishop I would assume
to defend g6 what is white achieved with
this on dressed I think Sam has to be
real careful so EF was played and now
Sam doesn't necessarily have to play GF
let's see what his ideas are here didn't
do the time GF might only serve to
activate blacks Bishop but on the other
hand no if G is coming - yeah I'd be
tempted with Queen d6 here it seems to
I'd the g6 pawn as well as young 6-4
let's put that on the board so clean d6
and a lot of threats to deal with from
the black site
still like let's say I just bring this
dude in okay so I
I'll take Jesus will check and I'll take
aged six and then I got some choices but
let's say that's the natural one mmm so
DeForest seems very committal right to
open up that diagonal for Bishop f5 so I
don't know if I'm ready to do that just
yet is it too late to try to consolidate
with a move like Queen III just hoping
for a queen trade and then I guess that
end game looks looks more or less level
I have no idea I have no idea
I'm sure okay let's see let's just check
our variation here so he needs
definitely to do something like Queen d6
and he's thinking let's just look at it
from his eyes cuz he's got another you
have anything else
there is always kind of an idea to do
things in the other order something like
e six immediately to try to take that
file would come to my head but I don't
know if it's actually achieving much
because my rook will come to ei pretty
quick right I will come to eat it my
idea was going to be Bishop takes c6
I'll play rook e1 and then if you play
rook e8 I'll double on the on the e-file
oh you know what there's another problem
with Queen d6 that he's thinking about
so if I check mm-hmm I think king b1 is
how I want to respond and then we're
seeing c6 I mean ah this is this is a
good way I mean maybe you can
I think Queen b8 I just go King age 7
yeah you seem relatively safe over there
I thought if you were gonna go down this
road you'd have to do this weird move
but it freaks me out to know it freaked
me out too
I'm worried about a couple of things
here but me maybe yeah maybe yeah it's
just wait tonight on d1 isn't never
going to be of any help in these
positions I think and that's probably a
problem yeah so okay that's one of the
concerns about Queen d6 well Queen b6 or
C eight maybe nine c3 is actually
something you can consider the idea is
if you play your exceed six now I have
why I guess I don't have Queen d5 and
also the pen hmm it's quite difficult
yeah it's a real funny thing where Sam
went for it and a lot of times this
happens when you go for the attack and
then all of a sudden your pieces are dis
coordinated and it suddenly may be black
the great positional maestro Ganguly who
has managed to find a way to bring his
pieces together and yeah I could tell by
Sam's body language he thought he was
winning this I kind of thought he was
winning it too and a lot of salmon on it
had to do you know it's funny - it's
like let's see what he does he played
queen bee for a that was an idea I was
about to mention get out of here okay
there is also maybe Perpetual ideas on
the Queen here if Sam feels like he
needs to bail out something like for
example rook g3 energy one in this
position would be kind of a perpetual on
that Queen
okay so I'm just gonna let's just show
up a variation so the idea is if takes
rook F to Queen h3 this is a very all of
a sudden is a huge initiative yeah so
Queen d4 now the threat it's got to be
as obviously rook F to Queen d5 and
maybe eg takes F there's a lot of a lot
of good things happening for white after
rook F - okay and so we're claiming that
rook c8 is nothing that my may or may
not be true well it might help white
play
I think Knight c3 is a move white would
like to play now that the Queen has the
dark squares under control well remember
if you play Knight c3 though then
there's no work f2 after F G that might
be but rixy a king b1 and you can just
hold your same idea okay
so what to do yeah that's a nice move I
feel like there's gotta be a move here
for black butt so I also don't know yeah
what can you just
perhaps Bishop e6 might be a move just
to defend that that D poem I don't it
seems way too slow right because it
seems like I'm gonna play it yeah and
then I'm when I play GF you're gonna
eventually have to yeah well let's let's
try it out so Bishop e6 rook F to Queen
age 13 Age 3
now there's I can throw in this move but
maybe I don't want to visit Queen h4
mm-hmm
but anyways so let's just see this one
and then so snip maybe still Bishop
takes
I'm not sure if white ever made a made a
serious threat because if you take D 5
out I'll take on D 3
or maybe I'll check you and then take on
DT okay so let's try this
so can we actually step back a couple
moves here I'm sorry I want to throw in
a rook c8 check before I start moving my
queen around because then in this line I
think it makes a huge difference sorry
and let's just note that on Queen d3
yeah I was worried about that
wait no and that not that one no I don't
know actually maybe you can't do this so
yeah and I wanted to throw Andric c8 so
I could take this pawn with with check
here to make it a little more first
thing even right okay so but if that's
the case let's see if we can do better
here for white so Bishop e6 you almost
have to start with York f2 right what
else do you
I guess you could start with your g3
instead I can also start with GF
immediately okay right because then I'm
holding the pawn and there's so let's
say here
okay I'll still play Bishop takes
all right I'll play I'll play rook c8
before it's too late and because I
always want I want to have this move I
think it only improves my pieces it's
all play you're seeing
late c3
v6
right I will move my rook since you play
rookie seven
I don't know if I you uh Rick g6 is your
plan now I know I still don't know
what's going on maybe like a fate or
some strip g7 even oh yeah better better
idea or riff g7 yeah and I I don't know
you know I I'm just gonna be honest I
have no idea like Queen you know there's
so much look at what like rook g7 that's
here the danger is can I do some weird
Queen f6 stuff still but right okay so
more for you heart out there
here we are that's a great game that's
the only game of the day and I all right
I think blacks my gut is that blacks
okay but that the Queen d4 was at least
a good yeah I move to put a lot of
conversation yeah why don't we take a
look at the C group before it's too late
we get invested in Sam's game so let's
check out those pairings Christian
shrila is paired against Dmitry
Gordievsky Brandon Jacobson is paired
against tournament leader archers Naik
Suns and then our key matchup for the
day is Iran poco bein playing it's all
Shawn Marathi Abadi both of these
players having kind of up and down
tournaments both of them actually
scoring a win and round five and scoring
a loss in round six so hopefully they
came back on track today and they have
quite the interesting game to show us
yeah it's been a real struggle and it
kind of seems like maybe white is just
simply on top now I don't know let's
let's just see what happened here but so
it went now we got Queen takes e5
well white looks completely winning now
right not a huge mathematician yeah
pretty good three pawns in front of
White's King and I don't know you can
maybe claim the H pawn is defending the
black King but not not especially yeah
so Queen takes c6 happened and then
Knight f4 I assume Knight h4 is also
possible I think there's just way too
much space in front of it blacks came
for him to survive this right let's go
back there was a very interesting game
um you know else on almost every opening
play something a little bit provocative
I feel and I think I've faced him and
it's like this kind of interesting thing
where he gives you a little rope and you
think it's rope to hang him but it's
actually often rope to hang yourself
and so with vision before we get this
interesting position where else Shaun is
now going to try to play on the light
squares and here I felt that white could
play c4 and maybe have a small edge but
it's probably about roughly equal so I
want to mention ya highest rated player
I've ever drawn I actually played this I
was blind very similar to this
and I played c4 got rid of my only
weakness and then I still suffered an
endgame for 80 moves he let me off the
hook but see if I can draw a GM in this
position or a position very much like
this I like around hagopian's changes
well around place f3 ah yeah and what
it's this interesting thing where he's
going to say look Oh Shaun you can have
my Seaforth square and I want to give
I'm going to play e4 and say it's a big
deal so queen c8 e for Queen a6 Queen c2
castles and here is this interesting
moment where else Shaun is basically
saying
that this is so tough when you're
playing a real game I feel he's saying
Bishop g5 fundamentally won't work
because I'm just gonna move the knight
so this is what happens right and he's
saying okay look buddy if you ever play
Knight f4 to go after my only weak spot
on d5 what will happen is I will have
either f6 Bishop h4 g5 forking the
minors or I'll have h6 Bishop h4g fine
so a rom says all right let's do it
and an interesting thing about this to
me was that in a certain respect you
could say that hoe Cobian was forced to
play this way because if he doesn't if
he doesn't manage to get something here
he will just eventually be worse on the
light squares so he's got to go for it
and it looks like it went well so now
with h6 I think the problem was a little
simpler than the game which was Queen f5
and I don't know let's just say you
protect the night somehow worst case
scenario I can do this
and it seems like it should be me or at
least very close to me yeah it takes a
lot to to play this though maybe but
that's the thing you don't have that
when you're forced into this variation
like cocoa bean essentially was like
then you just do it Queen at 5 and here
was a big choice for El Shawn I was
talking to GM l/100 Ramirez and we were
looking at rook f7 here and that also
looked like a huge mess after just
various moves after rook f7 in addition
to Queen d5 there's Queen g4 but it we
didn't find anything
totally concrete there's still even
Bishop g5 that would be the first g5
though you're you do activate the rook
okay so you're playing rook g7 because
I can take on f7 and check well I can't
do rook g7 because you'll play Queen d5
and takes c6 that's what I meant it's
take on d5 of check so I gotta go here
King h8 I'll still take d5 yeah and I
better have a way to protect my business
some yeah no I
it's a lot of puns but I got rid yeah I
don't work yeah I'll take on c6 that's
the one that I want and then I got to
come back somehow with either CA or
something
yeah I'll play just Queen d6 and I don't
think I don't think white is really
risking much here and I think the black
king is is pretty weak for for him to
survive this rigged up six I'll play
Queen v4 and I just want to play Rickey
one next and get some pieces in there
sure enough no and this is what I we
looked at similar stuff I think white
might be able do better than this but
okay we were looking at similar stuff
and we couldn't find anything concrete
even though it looks very dangerous for
for black in the game Queen c8 didn't
feel right and so then it was checked to
the miserable King and now a very nice
move that white plays here that I'm
gonna guess I'll shine didn't appreciate
when he played Queen c8 which is bring
the rook in you can take either piece
your choice and when I come down here
I'm gonna I'm gonna kick your night off
of that square and he sacks it on e5 but
if you go away let's say to a5 the
bummer is rookie 7 and then it's just
gonna be made yeah that that looks like
checkmate to me
so this maneuver rook e1 ricky 6 very
strong and after this sacrifice i think
we need to say that at least intuitively
white is winning because the king is so
much weaker and there's still just the
same let's say moves right eventually a
rookie 7 or well after xt6 I guess works
c7 yeah this is snip this is this is how
we this is how we end up finding
ourselves into the game continuation
Knight f6 and now Knight g6 is pretty
brutal because if you play HG I have
this out the pin you know black is
hoping that this pin is gonna save him
so he plays King g7 snip-snip night at 4
and I guess I'm gonna say that that's
lost I like taking the pawn on h4 why
did he take the bun on h4 it's maybe it
doesn't matter but that looks yeah I
don't like take
like thinking pods so Sean's thinking
about it um and the bummer I guess is
simple well what can black survive no he
cannot but he I guess that's what he's
gonna have to try something like I mean
this son game is I don't know if you can
even call this a try in the son game
simply wreck be one you can't even
defend a seventh rank right because if
Rick see seven days ninety six check
working making the wreck and I just
wanted to take that bomb and h4 then I
would have anyways so this is a really
nice game today and you know it kind of
like shows how tactics and strategy are
related because when black pushes it and
goes for it with this plan of Queen C
excuse me
with Knight ft7 you know playing on the
light squares
I shouldn't even just say it's not just
Knight ft7 it's all of the other moves
where you're playing for the c-4 square
it's like white says well you're gonna
get it but you've discordant ated your
pieces enough that all of a sudden you
know it doesn't look like it's gonna
happen now but by force that black king
is gonna get opened up it's tough it's a
difficult difficult line to play I think
so why don't we take a look at what the
players are playing for up near the top
now that we've seen a few of their games
and the prize fund for the a group is
$40,000 in total the first place getting
$12,000 second with 9k and third place
was $7,000 the B group also has quite a
bit of money in it first place is 6,000
second place five thousand and third
place to 4,000 the total prize fund of
$21,000
and finally the C group they are playing
for first place park prize of $4,000
second gets three thousand and third
place it's two point five thousand
dollars for a total prize fund of
fourteen thousand dollars this is nearly
or I think is actually double what the
prize funds were last year
so this tournament is growing and
there's a lot at stake here in all of
these games
the players where do you want to jump to
next Jesse let's go back to group a
we'll look at Sam's game we'll give an
update there all right
and so after Queen takes a three which
we had before
why didn't didn't play rook c3 we assume
there was other moves there too
and now Sam found nothing better than
this continuation where arguably he's a
little bit worse all of a sudden so what
happens this and it looks to me like
we're just headed for a clean draw yeah
the e4 pawn not going to survive the day
it looks like maybe black can make us
make a little bit of a claim that if
anyone's impressing its and really just
because of the the weaknesses maybe
after like g5 it's that we're here right
III would like to at least make you
wonder about g5 and make you wonder
about Ricky - no but okay it should be a
draw we're not so that maybe later when
I see Sam later I'm gonna ask him about
this move here and what he didn't like
about Knight takes e5 cuz I thought I
thought that was his idea
right you know in that current position
that we have yeah is there ever any
danger to the black king after something
like knight c6 well of course it's black
to move yeah so 96 and I want to play
rook b8 check and then 97 and maybe I
that F pawns somehow if I can manage it
or maybe I'll play even Knight g8 to f6
yeah you give me 7 moves I'm gonna check
me but remember I'm gonna play g5 at
some okay or at least I want to you know
I guess even immediately g5 is something
to worry about know why it's thinking
now like do I bring do I go back for
defense or if if I was gonna make
counter play I think it would be
something like rugby 7 knight c6 98 go
after the F pawn directly that makes a
lot of and the knight on c6 is
reasonable anyway because it'll help
fend off against g5 stuff right with
that extra defender I think there's a
lot of resources for white to at least
be able to hold yeah okay guys I got to
show you this other game head away and
play today against daro alright and it's
been a real interesting game where I'm
gonna take us I'm just gonna bring us to
what I'm gonna call the critical moment
really interesting opening lead here but
led us to here but let's just start here
and black is under a little bit of
pressure right but in in this position
he makes like a big decision and takes
on c3
alright so when you play this you've got
to worry about a lot of things you have
to worry about a rook landing on c7 you
have to worry about the immediate d5 and
you've got to worry about the slow h4 h5
well I need to see where all this time
like yeah the real big brief actually
yeah this is gonna be an incredible time
Scrabble coming up and for one of the
few times in history who wayne jones has
more time and his opponent right down
for the history books my goodness so
when you imagine you've got all these
moves to think about Gawain plays Queen
f4
and you know that's the mood that you're
probably not even gonna guess the other
guess is kind of almost almost a head
scratcher for me I don't I guess he's
just he's controlling more dark squares
with this smooth but with so many
immediate things that white could play
it's interesting that he chose this kind
of slower move well let's just show a
couple ideas me yeah so if rook AC one I
think is something like Queen d2 and
it's hard to move either rook yeah and
then you know the Queen might even come
back to g5 as well so that's that's
that's windshield grief also one benefit
to Queen f4 is controlling that DT
square good that's right that's right
and if you do it this way this is
another was another possibility that I
was looking at and in this position I
believe after a move like Bishop d5 I
couldn't really find anything special
despite the fact that this looks so
brilliant okay then of course there was
this move and that's just a holy moly
kind of thing where the only thing me
and me and I wander we're looking this
do so Queen before rookie for looks
crushing but then you play Queen d5 and
it's like oh maybe there isn't any body
blow here that's like a miracle if I can
really get away with all of this and the
idea is that the second you take here
then I'll play a fine right and
especially with the Rukmini for it
that'd be rather unfortunate with even
the bishop on b7 so these are some of
the motivations behind Queen c3 and I
think positionally it's it's not a claim
to say we're gonna win upon and then win
an endgame it's like a claim that we're
in a little bit of desperation and I
have to do something extraordinary to
hold the position Queen c3 is never a
movie you want to make it's never like
yes I took a pawn oh boy so Queen f4
put on your seat belt technician rookie
c1 Queen D for work
now another great thing about queen of
fors world by holding the seat file
there's no like Bishop b3 rook b3 and
then Rick ACA business or said so queen
a3 that's a difficult move to find rook
c3 snip-snip
Queen a to again the Queen is doing this
annoying dance with the rooks preventing
them from moving
now however White says d5 and says now's
the time
Oh buddy Daraa okay wait we got some
moves
so d5 happened takes Bishop d4 Queenie
five is the threat and black played
Bishop C fun now we have to wonder did
it go big going blow it here yeah I'm
wondering again no mathematician but
three pawns to six pawn jeans white
better have a whole lot of something
here or else you know he's got twice the
number up on system like it's well let's
ask the first question can I do okay I
could play this move first but I just
want to say the idea is Bishop f6 right
what to do after Bishop f6
now one good piece of news freeze you
can you have the takes on f2 night and
in fact I'm not threatening Queen age 60
yeah I am are though threatening this
studying six maybe you should throw in
there could be two first just to try to
take away this Bishop takes f2 option
but right now I think Bishop f2 is a
loser because I take it and the bishop
on f6 is a bomb right yeah well I mean I
can't I don't see anything else really
maybe Ricky eight now one bummer here is
okay Ricky a yeah
and I go here and there's no sack here
unfortunate because I can get oh they
just play Quincy for about what's the
problem well okay let's look Quincy
forward oh yeah let's just point out we
need ya know for some reason like I
thought Queen age sixes let's make no
matter what but there is just this
Bishop FA move
so Rick fe8 let's put that is like
that's got to be in try number one
shrine number oh my goodness okay
Queen Queen age six here
no there's Queen okay so there's the
sacrifice right the Queen age seven but
there's there's queen f2 unfortunate
it's also databases there's Bishop h6
nothing works
this idea is bogus okay so but besides I
got really excited there so besides this
though there's a real earnest question
of like well what else could white have
right sides Bishop f6 hmm oh my god he
took I see fine oh no that can't be
right and he needs something amazing
that oh this is you got a Wayne buddy
that's so oh you were rushing as you
were crushing it
oh man okay let's let's look at this for
just a moment cuz it really fell apart
there so Brooks III it looked right
let's just say it looked right this was
clever though Queen a2 and the idea of
d5 was to bring the bishop back but it
it didn't do anything except trade the
bishop off maybe a you needn't have
you're gonna do h4 for example you would
do it now I want to see maybe Rick takes
b3 was was the loser move here because
it well it allowed this Queen to
immobilize both those rooks like that
you know anyone
either a takes b3 or even taking it with
with the other rook might be something
to consider honestly anything seems
better than well yeah I mean it's easy
to say looking back but but even this
one he did you would think that h4 now
yeah this is something that has what if
black simply plays f6 right but that we
can claim there's a little the queen is
not next to her man and we can claim
something about that is it special no
it's not that special
I mean I'll just take it you know yeah
you know if one of my points okay is a
little more sensible perhaps I really
felt I really felt in this position that
Gawain was gonna he's been playing so
well this third what I've been room for
I thought for sure there what he was
gonna at least put some heavy juice on
it
and he must let's just say he must have
blundered something like maybe just the
simple Bishop c5 he plundered yeah and I
mean that move looks difficult to meet
so in the game white is saying I have
practical chances to draw and maybe have
true is that I'm down three pods it's a
lot that's a lot of puns and there's
ways now very easy ways for the black
queen to make its way back to the end of
the position right yet Queen e4 is the
most natural option just offering a
queen trade and bringing you back some
defenders yes I guess I guess we're
gonna have to say this would be da Rose
first win he's played great but he's
really suffered amongst the geniuses in
the ground it was a very very tough
field I do want to mention in this group
a that David Howell has drawn his game
against Lee Anne Lee they're the two
leaders and as well as Jeffery Zhong has
actually drawn his game against Sam
Shanklin so no surprises there for us so
with this game heading towards may be a
win for Darius that would
leave Liam Lee and David Howell will
actually both tied for the lead going
into the last two rounds and we see the
players their backs got complying of
time it's got plenty of oh well I don't
know two minutes is plenty of time for
thirteen moves I guess in this position
and I can do a CA so let me give a
report in Group B we have tournament
leader Oberon winning against excuse me
drawing against Daniel three yes why
don't we check back in with Sam let's
act like let's second check in with Sam
the lesser times that Viet I shouldn't
go on the lesser so let's go to where we
had it before as Queen before we
correctly predicted Bishop e6 rook f2
and there were other moves there yeah
snip-snip
a 93 that's that's about we hadn't
looked at check to the misérable King
and then
okay defy this is not is capturable is
not captured well also g6 is capturable
g6 oh well this can't i don't white must
be must be doing quite well okay but
let's think about it for a second one
thing g6
I don't think it's gonna be that strong
let's say you give a check you have to
have something here or else well it I
guess you have several things actually
FG - maybe yeah the end game after
something like Rick have to check looks
just dead lost right that epon will just
win the game so I'm of course thinking
about Rick have to check Rick takes up -
Rick takes up to check Queen takes up
two and then King takes g6 for the Queen
end game but the pawn on e5 it would be
winning there go here for say the Queen
d4 was a very nice move you know like a
messy position snip snip 93 another nice
move maybe even the I'm not sure this
check helped black actually I don't know
King d2 seems to help kind of
consolidate protecting d3 protecting III
freeing up some pieces so Knight takes
f5 has not happened yet no it has
something we're looking at this is all
force though right I think so yeah York
g2 and how do you prevent checkmate
now just my instinct is that rook f2 is
losing but let's Jack
so here surely it must be here no I
can't do that yeah I think I've to and
then there's Queen f6 check and then
just eat six right away yeah okay so I
don't know that that's the easy there in
like we said there's maybe the option of
taking on d5 at some point as well I've
seen enough after Nick Knight takes f5
I'd be ready to slam that move down my
opponents got five minutes
I think about we takes d5 what do you do
at what is black do after that that ref
is what is that - I like having that D
file close though I don't I don't want
that file in front of my king to be half
open but I it looks it looks winning
everything looks winning here okay Sam
is taking his time though let's take a
look at this amazing Kovalenko game sure
I've had a chance to hang out with Igor
a little bit and we just analyze a
little bit and he's a very passionate
player and so when I was watching the
game today we had this amazing opening
that white played look at this opening
a3 this is the goo booze Ian special
right now black and do of course a
number of things and it seems like this
should be good for black but check it
out right away goo boozy and like kind
of knew what he was doing here and then
Queen c2 Queen e7 g4 and Kovalenko you
could see his body language the guy was
swarming yeah he was really squirming in
this position who wouldn't have to Jake
for a my goodness look at this now
Bishop g2 castles now normal people here
would play Knight takes e4 check it out
though boom nineteen c4 might have even
been stronger but h4 was more evil so we
got this
and I was looking at this and I was hard
for me to understand like I felt like
White was definitely better hmm but how
much better was unclear to me so it
became very critical right away with b6
d4 takes and here there was an
interesting question mark of how strong
is f3 looks I'm gonna go somewhere
between really strong and very strong I
don't know it looks pretty good right so
there was that chance and let's just I I
don't know
there the problem of course is you're
killing your g2 bishop yeah but the
upsides are something like this right
you can take h6 maybe and stick that
King on f2 you're preparing something
like e for perhaps well first we'll take
this pawn somehow yeah I'll take what
the pawn I think I like that it keeps
your D pawn a little bit in check I
don't wonder about [ __ ] basics yeah I
wanted to play E for well this was a
position that he's maybe know their
position actually is kind of spooky
watch because now I'm starting to get
like check checks and weird stuff
running yeah I like it better with my
mic hang on F to you maybe anyways this
was the other choice that he had here
and I'm sure he contemplated this he
chose the positional route and I'm clear
now now the night will get to go back to
f6 unmolested so now we just have a
regular issue game ok and
white clearly thinks he's much better
here is it true I don't know let's look
he just wants to do it the positional
style and here he's got bishops but I
don't this doesn't look like too much to
me right he can always say that he that
the d5 pawn is making the bishop is
blunting the bishop bonds you too right
so we get this biz is playdate anyways
eventually yeah and it looks like what
black is holding on this is the mess we
got oh man
some of these moves I no idea yeah I
don't know the bishop maneuvers to c7
for some reason yeah I guess why it's
just putting it all on the a pond
putting it all on the a pond but with
the LightSquared bishop you would think
like an at least told the a a square I
don't know if maybe a seven is his plan
and then Bishop e8 and you can kind of
claim that your bishop is is keeping
that rook in check is that something
that I can Wieck and try here that would
be my instinct yeah that's what he's
thinking about
I have to say let's just talk about this
position there were moves earlier on I
have no idea what was going on there
and here black is wondering about King
takes h4 so King edge for if you can't
play King takes age 4 it's a little bit
of a bummer but well on being h4 you got
a wonder about your if you check
wreckage 1 and Bishop f4 I don't know
how dangerous this is though it can like
King f5 I can check you again let's see
running out of checks if nothing else I
can play Bishop takes age 16 just pick
up the pawn ok but when we go to this
position I'm not sure you know when you
if you dream about winning the position
mm-hmm
you do want to do something like you're
a 7 business and then you want to have
so plan after that you don't here's
maybe one idea what if you take h4 and I
play a7 what's your next move
cuz I might be threatening to play
Bishop d8 this should be a tie I can
sack the exchange in the X you might
want to worry about that
yeah also so h5 example h5
is there any more favorable way I can do
this like Bishop f4 you might play g3
well well that would just take on f4
immediately but g3 sure interesting I
don't know those two Kings side pawns
definitely look a little intimidating
so okay he did not play King takes a
chilly that was natural to the game and
he played rook g6 instead and he's in
elated as king a little bit the claim my
guess is that if you go back to g3 which
is the natural move yeah that he's got
some notion about how to defend this
thing no no this would be more of a last
resort in my opinion than so he must
have seen something he didn't like after
King takes h4 because it's the much more
natural way to try and a hold this or
even try to try to win this is getting
those two Kings side pawns and then I
claiming there they're worth whatever
white can drum up with the a pawn in the
bishop let's see if we can find it so
here
so this I what was wrong with this line
where we just checked and eventually
played Bishop takes page six nothing
necessarily wrong with it it didn't seem
like it was crushing black though well I
want to take off the H pawn and then I I
want to say maybe I have time to just
bring my pieces back and make the same
threats with my a upon o still play a7
I'll still play Bishop f4 and I'll still
play Bishop e8 and try to make something
work but imagine you're black you have
the choice between this position and
this position what do you take that is
the time question you posed that's what
I'm wondering if he must have felt like
there was something else more dastardly
here maybe Bishop f4 immediately yeah I
was thinking still g3 so check the
miserable King runaway and now either
one of the rooks to G
it's not impressive you know either Rick
2g1 maybe I can you know force the
sacrifice and take your Bishop and then
just h5 you know but if I do this room
you just take this thing this is not the
world matter there but yeah I even I
almost like for an advantage for black
where it takes that for in that visit
okay but black obviously didn't think
yeah so kh4 what is the problem
let's try this a seven okay
no I was most concerned with h5 that
there's you know g3 is another movie you
could do play g3 could I also play a
Rick ff8 just to stop Bishop d8 and say
I have plenty of time you know if you
the thing about those this rook is
terrible so if I could sacrifice it for
this bishop in that pawn yeah
so let's try that one h5 is natural
let's just see if I'm wrong so snip 88
I'm gonna say I feel good but no I feel
great about life I think yeah the bishop
comes to g4 and I'm black is there might
be some weirdness with like rook here
and then king g4 so I have to worry
about it looks like we have a result it
looks like those two pawns made it up
the board and Gawain Jones's game Oh
Dwayne buddy sorry about that that looks
like a win for daro to me that
definitely looks like a win let's show
that yeah coupons yeah it could be worth
a lot once they make it down the point
it's such a bummer this is the fate of
the attacking player though if you're
gonna go for it sometimes you have to
you trust your intuition and then you
miss a move or miss evaluate a move like
Bishop c5 and you realize you're just
toast
we're devastating seems like it might
fit here this this game has to hurt with
white you feel like you have something
there and then you find the find it in
you to go for it and that that is one of
the one of the one of the worst
backfires that I've seen and here we
have Sam also won his game I had that I
got like we said that that Yvonne did
tell the tale although they reached a
slightly different end games than we
were looking at that's look I was
similar though 93 and then he did take
so we got all that right now we got like
GT right Brooke if for sure
snip yeah this is it this is a nice idea
of course the Queen cannot be captured
this is immediately if you're black
totally toast do you want to show that
that checkmate
so Queen takes that four is working we
take set for look at for this is when
you go just oh yes yeah checkmate to the
misérable okay so very nice game by Sam
very nice game yeah I think that one was
well played so we're still waiting here
in
on this game with you go boozing and
Kovalenko I don't understand drip g6
there right there we they've reached
time controls though so that's no big
deal
Oh oh my god what is going on okay
haven't talked about Gordievsky in the
count oh boy
if Gordievsky wins a game you know he
would be yeah he'd be you catch ya catch
arteries and artists have been taking
busy the last couple rounds with two
draws yeah so this is this is the key
game kind of in the sea group period if
Dimitri manages to win this this
position which I would hate to have to
even play much less win then yeah he
catches the tournament leader with just
two rounds to go after this but
logically what do you think you have a
sense optically what's going to Cle
White's got a lot of pieces around his
King aimed at blacks King and black has
a random night on b3 a random Brook on
c8 and I think White's pieces make more
sense honestly okay I have no idea
what's going on the let's just say he
took he did take on f2 and now I could
do a number of things but I wasn't sure
what White was gonna do next regardless
of whatever black did okay what if I
play e5
and say that I am attacking your queen I
am attacking your queen that is one of
the questions that the count is now
asking himself right now
well while you're taking a look at this
we actually have daro here after his big
win against go angels yeah and he's
gonna come in for an interview so I'll
be stepping out of the studio all right
yeah so let's while we're waiting for
that let's just imagine a 5 it's kind of
a weird move because you know okay we're
in deep time pressure so anything had
happened here but if you were worried
about like be 5 and then f6 you could
play rook e8 now so let's just look at
this a5 business and what are you gonna
do Queen f7 I'm really worried about the
simple f6 and it looks really difficult
to do anything after that so if I've
just played
yeah and we're about to talk to daro
spirits and we're gonna catch up with
the other games when we come back all
right so we have Darla here in the
studio
pick up on this game yeah where would
you like to start
okay I mean lately my main opening on 34
was usually five I guess another Lopez
or Italian depends what it's doing okay
- - so - I might as well try to play
something more aggressive because what's
the point of you know making a drop all
right he tried to win so I said play
like stealing that I used to play for
many many years that's still right
uh-huh
so yeah yeah here you can use this mouse
over here
sure okay okay so I decided to play
second DC's which also normally normally
play because I go for neither he six I
saw that he plays either hopping or here
he goes for open season so I felt could
be good wait and surprise him and get
some playable position so we have minus
65 95 see for his operator like a line
which took the CD 84 should be seven
Rockcastle Castle and now he surprised
me of Technology six I wasn't sure
whether take of queen or bishop because
I saw he some of his games against
fiddler and it was very similar but but
it was way different because Knight was
on c6 right here is not gonna be able to
gives me additional options I thought so
that's why I thought they take the Queen
and comparing to the position to the
game of fiddler I have a additional
ideas present when I see three BC and
now b6 for example we've idea 97 96 at
some point sure
so this was my point I'm not sure if it
was the best move though because I
allowed 95 which is I 5 sorry but I
wouldn't sure it's like so-so
maybe Einstein was more accurate I worry
about yeah I was thinking about so so
just to be clear in the other game that
he had he played in this position nights
in three years
no no he played the rookie I mean he was
he sort of cut it was 96
I see I said of course oh it was 96
here was 96 indie Queen takes d6 rook e1
or 90 300 remember Castle naruki one
night when members of order Group D 883
and this was I mean it's kind of a
normal position but like I wanted to get
something something else
it was right we went to postpone
developing that from C and B 8 to 6
because I want to keep more options and
by taking here he also is interested
maybe to play rook Ewan's because if I
want to play knight c6 and India quaint
xt6 transpose us back to the Steelers
game sure so yeah maybe this was the way
to try ok this surprised me a little bit
okay 93 ok ok I can go up stance these
things which is normal but I wanted to
get this position will be 6 which is OK
and maybe I want to finish of 86
I wasn't sure maybe 90 cents more across
earlier it's difficult to say it's
probably no games in this position
already 95 96 which of the four ninety
five we should be [ __ ] we still kind of
normal and now I thought that you'd pay
either Bishop g4 we should be to be
should be three surprise me it's very
strong move because okay after now
Bishop can move the free our plan we
shall be seven Queen keep repeating 24
simply g6 and this is sorry sorry not g6
like I have additional option here f6 to
the point I wish upon goofy I don't have
this option right so and that's why we
should be ending Bishop e2
I go just b6 we should be for frequent
service as a completely composition I'm
fine
okay we should be free he played should
be 720 46 Brooke yeah I mean the only
move but I basically playing after
Bishop before head
very long lines basically I had to
calculate that after Bishop d7 group 24
g6 book everyone that I have to take on
c3 yeah we thought that was insane I
know it's very risky but I never I
couldn't refute it I couldn't refuse and
objectively I voted the best game the
best way for the game to proceed was d5
Queen before Queen takes before Bishop
takes before the e bishop he want takes
take a look again postponed I think
actually he can take you first rook e8
for example and if takes takes it should
be draw somehow let's say F for Bishop
ca I've perforce taking so I saw such
rise when why playing we should be seven
already which is is why I like fourth
time there but okay Queen before and
here okay like the white head or some
other options but the thing is that I
always have this defensive idea
like for example which was also that
during the game like we need three let's
say Queen Bishop here Queen h6 and f6
which is like basically cutting the
entire attack so we a quintic C free and
well you spend heroes of a long time and
okay also there is d5 couldn't before
Ruby for I thought about Queen C 5 and I
wasn't sure what's next for for white
because you know like the respond only 5
hanging there is no clear how to had no
clear how to attack I guess he made yet
and I always have this f6 move so I
thought why it may be taking like
excessive it which was kind of after
Quincy free I was stupid hoping that he
will start push it like over pushing
because it was very promising but there
is no kind of clear way I didn't see a
list how to you know get like you know
very you said yourself I don't see a
refutation so I'm just gonna do it yeah
but basically I bother about the main
line I had to calculate was Queen before
because if I know about Queen before is
very forcing and basically attack the
Queen hit on the Queen and
like I know here's to either take or
move somewhere here but don't if it
moves there just simply take enough 6 so
this that's the point and it's not so
easy to kind of refute this idea so here
he played Queen f4 which is very
interesting but I thought I thought it's
not not correct
I'm not sure maybe it's winning I don't
know but I always have this after I'm
facing my plate we should be assured if
I only move but I was so confused here
because I had for example a g5 which was
interesting
and after queen g4 just queen d3 when I
come back here and where is the attack
I'm just pulling up and ok here's a
compensation but like there is no mate
because of course is a exponential
creations that will prevent it in the so
either be 75 or g5 so but but I wasn't
sure about this position it's kind of
like compensation you know like because
of making this kind of week so please I
do play ok be shunned if I was my first
photo case just go for it I 2006 I was
only with hip bones found some made here
that's why I was double checking myself
triple checking myself but like I
couldn't see anything so because he's
been like half an hour there and he
played this then he playbook see one
very quickly I'm not sure this is the
best move I mean I don't know it doesn't
feel right because it doesn't feel right
in this because you know he's taking his
pieces out of you know the I was like
feeling some maybe rope
81 then tonight maybe some work here
Queen before some rookie free something
like this made a yeah this is something
like but then there's some ideas Queen
d2 maybe we're just not so clear at all
give one is sorry sorry 22 room d1 yeah
so rookie free but I can
there is no Fred right there is okay
there is maybe row page three fret but
still I can exactly I may play Joseph
six yeah and you know there is no follow
up basically for white so and this is
one of the drawbacks of Queen f4 is that
everything becomes this big monster yeah
that's true
let me ask what let's go back to this
decision I'll move a team what about
just like a human move like h4 how do
you think what you think about that
position unclear unclear okay that was
just no the instinct then we're looking
at this with your coach with your coats
in the other room we are and we were
very surprised Queen c3 but I guess it
works yeah it's it's it's very
provocative I was I wanted like the
restroom and I was thinking to myself
okay
it's a least provocative and I don't see
refutation so let's just see what
happens right right right okay Thank You
queen of four okay
five yeah couldn't beat also supposed to
I'm not sure which was but I want to
keep the official protection any case
but anyway like first of all with this
okay this is like I saw some nice like
yeah like for example this there's a
three for example no a frequent be to
this doesn't bring anything because you
know it doesn't get anywhere so yeah
like if he takes take some rock c7 looks
very interesting but like it's just f6
and I see what's next
it could be just waiting for black so
because this these pieces are lacking
coordination here
I'm not sure about what like I was
worried for during the game so yeah he
later gave me one which is logical queen
a3 Roxie free and at first I thought to
play here f6 but then I suddenly
realized that maybe like a super trick
of some weird move the Queen III haha
yeah that's fine but it's like some
total mess going on I don't know what's
that possibly I can just take but take
stakes
okay some possibly I mean I should be
fine but some Bishop d6 move okay I'm
good we pulled up but it's kind of like
still unclear right which is weird
I mean some weird lines well okay why
just not to take because for example if
he goes this is what happens this day my
entire defensive idea here let's say
Bishop h3 or gate 3 f6 twin h6 we have 7
nothing that's it right right so if he
doesn't have did any admitting ideas
here it's just winning 4 black because I
just collect the pawn and you know like
if I'm coupons up and there is no
continuation of the attack and yeah it
seems like if he's gonna do this he
should play h4 now 5 6 and at least in
time pressure after Bishop d6 he can
keep playing yeah
possibly possibly it was actually a
maybe if because I just kind of like a
tamale move but maybe I can play first
time rook a d8 but maybe but also I have
ideas of Queen c2 maybe on Queen of five
no of course you should be there should
be more than one yes it's just in the
game it was so weird whether wait yeah
but I think witness queen of Queens very
precise because I basically activate my
queen and
but your difference and I can see any I
can think of any you know problem here
maybe eight five Queen five this is but
all of I hope we never lose over this is
good you know yeah was all these rook
moves and actually they didn't lead to
anything it just led to the rook sitting
on be on the B file yeah we're doing
they were more active before yes I think
this Queen's were active and kind of
ties them up yeah it's okay is he played
d5 we just kind of like last last gas
right yeah let's try to confuse things
we should be for an OPEC for Bishop c5
is just doing I think about six I simply
can go to cookie eight because there is
a hit on f2 so he couldn't have also I'm
sure it is
yeah but if he goes this I can I can go
either up as well because if this is the
screen of don't sure just wins because
suddenly I have perfect coordination
McQueen Alito yeah so he took okay man
there is this kind of like okay I just
squeeze it with Quincy to to put my
queen back to the game OOP seven logical
24.7 okay and here just started pushing
my pawns and the rest I think it's
straightforward because I simply put all
my poison he can stop them well
congratulations great game it must feel
good after a tough tournament yeah yeah
it's right after was missing witness
against yesterday I was completely when
you guys David Howell I here's a fragile
creatures mentoring is Jeffrey and what
else I mean almost all my white games
were like with huge advantages or like
nearly winning positions okay well
congratulations and we're gonna get Sam
seven in to talk about his very eventful
win and thank you very much alright so
while we're getting Sam set up I'll just
roll through some of the other games to
see what's going on
here and all drawers yeah all drawers
except for Darwin's win in Group A and
then in Group B Ganguly as we saw lost
and Igor is still planned against
caboose e'en in this position which I
didn't understand after Rick g6 Bishop
g3 rook a7 he gets another chance at 87
g3 g4 I'm gonna skin admit I don't
understand so what is the idea of oh
yeah Divi 4 is 2 if you take there's
gonna be drama with rook c5 check I
guess I guess that's what's going on so
we had a tight end game going on there
the count looks like he's doing better
against Gordievsky but it's a bit of a
mess and here we have Sam's all right
and then else John and Coby and drew
wait we're gonna have to talk we're
gonna talk about this game after our
interviews and maybe Sam will help us
understand so we're here with Sam Savion
who had a very nice game today and we're
going to talk about it here
okay when we take it away Sam works yes
Oh be kind of surprised me a little bit
with the French uh-huh and I played oh
it's this whole I think okay and I
played slightly realign with dc5 and he
seemed like he didn't say hadn't seen
that yes that's right so he played
bishops which I wasn't sure about I
spent some time here I thought I have a
nice smooth 94 in his bishop right but
then I noticed that he has h5 if I play
Queen g7 Ruby 8 and move the Queen
somewhere he plays Queen e5 check you
know I have to go back and he plays d4
and I lose a piece okay yeah and if I
play sorry if I play after h5 Queen h4
he plays Quin 85 check and initially I
thought this should be true and I'm just
winning but then I noticed doubled
affliction should pick stuff - oh very
nice very nice uh-huh so this was kind
of annoying and I decided to play just
develop it Bishop d3 it seemed like the
bishop is misplaced on c5 yeah it could
be misplaced on c5 yeah yeah especially
because I always have ready for ID right
so he played Queen b6 here I considered
this coffeehouse idea with Knight f3 aha
Bishop takes f2 kinky - and I wanted to
play rook f1 I do find just go for a
question attack but after Bishop c5 it's
not as easy as I first thought but
Knight h3 it's doing all the same thing
yeah true true the only problem with
Medich there is it doesn't really
support the e5 pawn but I do play off
force so I didn't like Knight d7
actually I think he should have played
Nate b c6 blacks main idea is if white
doesn't put f4 and tries to castle
immediately with Bishop d2 black has a
nice defense 90/65 we take c7 9 takes T
363 Bishop d4 yeah
so therefore I played f4 therefore I
think I should play at four right and
the difference with the knight on c6 and
d7 is that from c6 and I can play you
can play night before in some positions
and get rid of this annoying respond you
threw all right like for example you can
play Knight g6 and if I play Bishop g2
maybe he can play night before so that's
an idea black guys okay he played 97f
here I was pretty much happy because now
I got Bishop d2 alone castle and my
leader Bishop won't be attacked so he
went g6 you should be too he played
Bishop e3 I think that if I was an
interesting alternative here the ideas
if I play 94
I mean c7 and Knight takes e5 Knight 65
yes his darks words are really weak but
he doesn't want to take on d3 and if I
take on f5 he has this monster Michael
Cooke coming to you for sure
meanwhile my knight on h3 isn't it that
seemed weird like he's playing Bishop
III so that his knight can come to c5
yeah yeah right it's so bad for him
there should be that I think is a
inaccuracy for sure so long Castle takes
takes 95 Queen h4 basically I'm not
letting him play but should be sent
along Kissel because I'm putting prime
me and your magician look great yeah I
really like wait here another idea I
have is to play Queen f6 for example if
Bishop d7 I play Queen f6 and if he
plays a rogue f8 I have a nice lady in a
g5 attacking h7 if an idea always
have--can g7 and this relates h6 are you
gonna at age 7 rook g8 and now I slide
back in my net come step 6 I'm gonna
blacks in big trouble so he played h6
your White has a boatload of plans
pretty much I mean Knight f3 Knight g4
is an idea and I can play for g4 f5 but
the thing is black has ideas too he
wants to play Bishop d7 and then either
d4 or rook c8 and try to maybe put some
pressure on C fun so I can't be too slow
one line I was looking at was night f2
okay and they takes t3 up takes t3 and
Knight f5 I have to play Queen f6
because my knight overhanging he castles
and what I didn't like is that after I
move by night here he plays 28 and
trades Queens now what will be better in
the endgame of course but it's not it's
not that easy hmm so I went g4 played
for f5
he played should be seven I thought this
was your big moment here in this
business is a very critical position
because the rook F one is very natural
with their different f5 as his Queen f6
but one of the thing I didn't like what
rook F 1 was that he plays d4 and now if
I play 94 which is what I do after
different and other positions
he takes Knight stakes and plays Queen
a6 and that's a nasty fork alright so
maybe rook e1 instead of red Calphalon
well the reason I played rook F 1 is to
support f5 because if I play a 5 here
will take and he will take on d3 and
then he will take on f5 and I want to
keep put the reference or against I
prefer an f5
right there but like let's say yeah I
don't know there's a bunch of moves you
can do here probably one of the reasons
it was hard
I was just wondering like what is he
even gonna do after work you want rook
e1 okay okay
and of course like the problem with rook
c8 is now he really isn't it yeah it's
being still considered so let's say
natural king b1
hmm maybe night a sixth even though it
looks weird I want to take on c3
and I don't really want to put moves
like they eat when they do one right
actually I don't know this is hard
I mean 96 I've be encouraged by though
that would feel no just feel good but
some kind of night move yeah one of
those I mean if there's a true knight
son b3 it's close to winning of course
right right but he has some ideas on the
clean okay fair enough yeah I thought it
was just like with Bishop d7 it felt
like okay then I can't barely move and
then this is like oh man now then then
you just three on fire yeah what for
this the g5 takes up seven I do and I
imagine this is really hard to cut
because he's got loads of he could play
Queen da he wasn't finding this movie
yeah it was pretty good yeah very nice
receiving right so can we get I think is
the critical move mm-hmm and here what
has some ideas one idea is to play rook
f1 and play for f5 but one mine and I
wasn't sure about was in 96 right so the
idea is to take on e5 yeah and really
complicated position it occurs after
King f8 now I can put either Queen h3 or
96 the thing I didn't like about 96 was
luck plays King g7 and if I play they do
takes up 70 plays hthe 5 Wow yeah no I
have to the queen of three but I don't
so I probably should play King f8 Queen
h3 but then I was clearing Knight takes
e5 Oh actually 93 check first because if
I take with the Queen he's still paying
but he'll take man I think the guy I
have to take with the rook no he takes
Knight takes e5
if I play F takes if I could plays Queen
takes d5 second and he picks up my other
it unbe 565 I'm sorry so I have to play
Knight takes c6 only move because Bishop
66
sixty-five and I wasn't sure how to
evaluate this position because after
Queen g5 he puts the King on g7 and kind
of you know which he has been getting up
maybe is okay so therefore after Queen
g8 I may have to play simple with Quinn
age three and then if he goes 96 I go
Knight f3 uh-huh and then my knight now
supporting b5 is much easier to get f5
in this is why I like the knight on f3
like if he goes back to b6 I believe I
can play a five here
he probably should take and pass along
yeah this maybe isn't the best oh yeah
hard to say who's better right because
ya know I think what's better because of
all the pressure on the King said but
maybe this isn't the most accurate way
to plate so I still think windy it was
the best move which gives way too many
options including King v1 by the way the
idea is to meet night six foot maybe
five again but then they take seafood
doesn't come with check maybe six so
it's kind of a dick move and if he puts
rooks eight then I played one so I would
probably play King b1 or Knight f3 okay
yeah so he went for more the sharper
than with Queen before of course I could
continue with rook F one which was my
initial plan but then I noticed after
rook c8 a three night 63 rook takes T
three Queens c5 he's threatening he's
not threatening d4 but he has d4 in the
air and he's definitely threatening but
should be fine because of the penalty
[ __ ] if I play Knight takes f7 here he
plays King takes f7 Queen f6 check King
g8 before and now black plays Queen c7
Queen takes
he's seven and rook h7 very complicated
issue right we see this coordination in
the game yeah very similar except no my
pawn ISM before my King bees weaker so I
decided to go for an immediate Knight
takes f7 to avoid this before move
I see yeah okay yeah and the reason I'm
avoiding it is of course if what she did
they take C three C takes D three King F
seven point F six kimi GA three if he
plays queen c5 now I have D four very
nice okay yeah so he plays the only move
Queen D four oh by the way if he starts
with after 95 some king takes f7 Queen
f6 check King GE I can play three but I
have an extra playing Bishop is g6 takes
takes King f8 and it looks like he's
made in Africa fauna5 Wow okay so
therefore he went for this Knight 63
and we got the position after Queen D
for Queen takes e7 rook h7
so I've won a pawn but my attack is kind
of gone now and he's going to play rook
f7 or cafe didn't put pressure on that
four o'clock yeah at this point I wasn't
sure I was entirely sure who was better
anymore you know it was really yeah I
think what has played some accurate
moves because if I play natural Queen f6
black plays room she's 7 it's not good
there's just one thing if I could go
back I'm interested in if I go rook F 1
in 7 I think you play it slow rook c8
a319 c3 rook takes you 3 Queen c5 I'm
thinking instead of going for like brute
force Knight takes f7 I can make a
slower move maybe Rudy - Rudy - or Regev
- that's what I'm thinking maybe around
52 it just scared me with the Brooklyn F
- yeah you know I'm actually playing for
a fun now this is interesting
well know that but like his King is like
it's just yeah it's just stuck in the
middle yeah okay so this was an
interesting alternative
anyways Knight takes a second I think in
that position you're also threatening a
94 at some point - oh yes I wanted to
mention that - after Rudy - what has a
nice idea of playing 94 and then all
these dark Spurs like just jumps in yeah
and it's nice that he can't go Queen c4
b-58 your rook is in 96 yeah so Knight
takes f7 okay now when we got this first
line check a 324
when usaron pitcher 17 before the
correct move and he definitely should
keep Queens on the board right because
if he trades Queens and and starts
putting pressure
what easily stops this in place 92 and I
have the dream end game with next report
all right right so he plays Queen III
and this is a really critical moment in
the game I had to cook great many lines
I have a 91 I can take on b7 which is
very risky
I have f55 was my first instinct the
point is I want to open up the kingside
obviously just line obviously it's a bad
move but if you take some place now if
he takes twice I played 865 25 route you
want King h8 rookie - and I'm meeting
him on the diagonal Kimi you can't
through it yeah I just noticed that okay
metaphor that's a Christian and with no
g6 all right yeah so he can't really
play gf5 the move I didn't like was rook
c8 so he's threatening to play d4 this
opinion these pins are really annoying
because I don't know I can't play King
do I can't [ __ ] see - and if I play
FG Ruby g7 g 4
I bigger ideas maybe Bishop eh now mr. P
AIDS
peaceful
the French players breathe yes yeah when
that comes to g6 design I might get made
it I need to feel really concrete here
Queen d6 well then I take the ribbon saw
you together but the problem is you six
every picks you through it
yeah that looks right six chicks
Brooksie - right yeah I guess this is
even better didn't pick up the word
someone yeah this is not good for it
yeah nice fish beats so so yeah this is
why I didn't like it rip c8 and then
it's not really clear how to continue ii
was considering was Brooke f1 now black
can play route f7 or continue the game
with receipt and black has some
initiative with default so I took
concrete measures here with 91 black
must play Queen f3 you can always throw
in receipt Joshua yeah so the key
position is after I mean if the rooks
you want now either he complain or cafe
or gets it all right he chose rook F
seven and I was very impressed by your
next move here because we were looking
at it and it was real hard real hard
thunders dad here
yeah so the point why I play f5 is well
first of all I want to open up the lines
the kingside and not just get f4 for
nothing I guess I should say I was it
was it was an f5 didn't press me but
then f5 then Queen 24 okay Queen d4 was
no I just want importantly and afters
yet if I take he plays rook c8 king D 1
and plays Queen takes f4 initially I
thought rook F 2 is winning when I first
played a 91 but then I started
calculating both rook c1 check and quits
you in check if rooks you want chef King
gay - then he has to sacrifice the Queen
for two rooks then I guess I get the
colony 7 he goes that crook Jeju I think
why it's better but it's definitely not
easy it works of reactive all right
ma'am and the second line which was even
more complicated map here's a queen c1
King roof takes F 296 f2 hoon take is g1
and Brooke f8 takes and no suddenly no
yeah
King g7
no your nights my night has nowhere to
go and just in Iceland I was affected in
Queen d7 check right now he has to go
back because it feels Rufus having fun
yeah takes Queen and what's better yeah
but I wasn't sure about the tour
expedition so I didn't go for this okay
I mean there's so many interesting lines
with look at fate but I'll stick to
regret seven so I went f5 uh-huh yes and
now queen g4 so the idea is to try
trapping the queen with rogue f2 and 93
no not trapping the queen but start
attacking with rogue f2 and a 93 all my
pieces yeah no that was a great move I
didn't see that coming that was great
the reason I played 24 was if I go 26
right he goes rip g7o interesting we
were looking at Ricky eight rook e8 I
hope they're okay too but I think you I
take her g7 yeah I take this and then FG
the net G and then at least I wasn't
certain what was happening mm-hm
your move is probably better though yeah
because here I'm up upon that can play
the crook you won and stay solid
yeah the point of the q7 is if I play
east six he goes Bishop c6 and position
is completely crazy so I see so many
options yet so I went Queen D for I
really like this move I want to play
rook F to G f33 you get all the
percentages for example if FG rook F to
Queen h3 Queen 65 it looks very strong
right or even gives them yeah we got em
first
I believe the best move here is F for
the idea is it's kind of a strange move
but it kind of closes my roses ikaw so I
have to throw cuff - Quinn H 3 and this
position was a critical window so I was
spending so much time so maybe if he's
gonna do that he should check first on
see a like before f4 before f4 just so
that your King can't come to d2 later
actually the game in the game in the
game variation he should've checked
first
haha in this variation this isn't very
helpful for black because now I take
Queen 65 and if he plays Bishop c6 okay
very sharp
I just noticed an idea that's why I'm
thinking queen bee three black goes
bishop before I think imagine is Pia and
white takes advantage of my thing on
this file Wow
and I think what Sweeney yeah this looks
waiting for it alright but in general
yeah he has to play something like f4 it
has to put f4 root Jeff tuqwan h3 now if
I go Knight c3 at least he can play the
endgame down upon that's why you didn't
want to give the check yeah that's why I
didn't wanna give this wreck
yes okay because of 93 Queen III yep and
here takes takes your check King d1 King
e6 take six
okay blacks down upon but there's
definitely fighting chance sure yeah
at for work f2 footage 3 I think I would
like Queen takes d5
now if Bishop c6 again Queen b3 or Queen
c4 and if rook e8 I was thinking about
Queen efore note that if I play rook
takes F for black fizzbin should be 6
and the second reason I didn't want to
give check was here I have Queen b5 like
as Internet so Luke see it that's why I
do you want to get chick over to keep
this check open and after there should
be 6 if Queenie for group takes g3 Queen
63 Queen takes f-14 and Queen takes d3
and my king is now open
yeah yeah yeah yeah therefore I want to
start with Queenie for attacking g6 and
then Knight c3 or maybe take it upon in
the floor so I think this was his best
chance after Bishop e6 I was really
happy no I could rip deaf to now if you
give check I just go to G - yeah
everyone I'll explain why that's what
you're saying if he's gonna go [ __ ] b6
he should check he should check first
let's look at this so if Queen d4 up CH
check King b1 Bishop e6 now I go route
f2 Queen h3
[Music]
G takes f five lipsticks f5 so first I
want to say the main difference with my
kingdom b1 black has after 93 a
brilliant move rook c4 Wow and if Knight
takes e4 Queen 63 2063 Bishop takes c3
and he picks up my rook very nice I play
Queen takes d5 which I initially thought
wins he has Queen takes me three and my
rooks are hanging if I take on f5 he
takes on g1 with check really annoying
so route c4 is the idea
yeah that looks good so that's why you
should give check first we've got to
Queen h3 but maybe I play something
different here for example I may play g
a5 Bishop f5 and I'd instead of 93 which
allows rip c4 I will play rook g3 what
black will have to play own age 5 and
now either 93 which allows this position
Brutus g6 King h8 which is very
complicated or I think 93 is the best
move to yeah this is I think the way it
has to play and now my king is very safe
at least I can put it on a 2 and he can
also now play Bishop e6 though he can
yeah I was thinking
okay pure madness baby-g fivers love
they got her fun eh for the problem okay
our boss is saying we gotta wrap it up
already wrap it up okay that's the game
so Bishop e6 alright what today so okay
recap to range three takes takes don't
where's the mouse okay 93 now Rick's a
check and again this is basically his
trap if King d1 Brooke c4 is the keeper
that's a nice one yeah
so King d2 here when it's close to
winning I want to play 96 f5 night 65 or
route g3 is an idea but he found a
resourceful defense that I just want to
show what is that you was a good Rick
cf8 now initially I wanted to play rook
g3 Quinn h5 965 which is very logical on
kinetics of six but then I noticed she
has Bishop takes d3 crazy now if Knight
f6 check these sacrifices exchange goes
back to f5 and my king is still stuck in
a very funny way it's not funny for me I
was thinking I can literally picks up
sound first yeah
Queen takes know here I thought we need
to check Quincy to check so I want to
win the bishop if you ever recaptures
but now it's a force checkmate check
check and 26 mates things can go wrong
if I go if I make a mistake so probably
I should play Knight f6 check and play
this complicate position but then
luckily I found this yeah yes nice
simple the simple move allows King gauge
seven by the way here to trick you here
I was planning to take Queen takes d5
and if he plays rook takes a fight
probably just chopped up seven choppy
seven been chopped f7 it should be one
yeah and go back work f2 and also review
on and push the pawns so he played route
6 f5 and now the conclusion
route 3 6 KH 7 group FG - now my attack
is too strong I want to play rook g76
mm-hmm
if you please rip chief I will take take
and play from 65 and if you plays rook F
to check someone important takes takes
takes King g6 now this is the first
instinct right uh-huh
but then he takes it plays d4 in whoops
so instead here I'll start playing Queen
f6 check engage v e6
Queen takes h2 King c3 Queen c7 check
King b3 my King Faisal a 2 and the Queen
in pawn will win the game Wow very
impressive so he has to play recap for I
play dough cheese - and check King h8
and I found the simplest I think thanks
if he takes it's checkmate yeah
so as to take on G to take stakes down
what has 6 probably wins it easily as
well but King III now black has hard
time stopping pawn if you go back I'll
just put the shoe we can use cut very
easy win and if you play rook a 4 I play
6 rook a 6 and rook g6
nice trick here 77 game over so he
played wreckage for I played he's 64 can
be too and they were can stop the fun if
you page 3 is 7 Ruki 352 with one party
very nice sound very nice yeah so yeah I
guess we're gonna wrap it up here what
would you get plus plus one plus one
that's a good result
wait this tournament is still wide open
here yeah alright wish you luck arrest
the tournament that was a beautiful game
I mean I'm sure when you turn on the
computer it'll say that both of you were
terrible but Gabe alright
congratulations thank you ok I think
we're gonna wrap it up here we're gonna
give a couple announcements and talk
about some of the events coming up and
actually let's see do I have time is
there any notable news that I should say
before we come back
Igor is still playing on and it's
totally unclear what's happening the
rook on a is trapped as predicted but
the Jeep on and the h-bond are free they
are free to roam down in the countryside
the count looks like he's in trouble by
first glance anyway count got a piece
for his troubles though he at least has
a piece for his trouble so the game
isn't necessarily over and as we said
before Ellis John somehow drew that game
which seems unfair to a cobia because I
don't know we don't even know how that
happened I wanted him to take that pawn
on h4 earlier that's all I know
alright it's a crazy stuff so let's
actually just jump right into the
standings and see we are leaving off
today group a all the games have
actually completed so Liam Lee and David
Hal still top the leaderboard but
they're four and a half score following
them still closely are Jeffrey Zhang and
Sam shank legs
Gawain Jones actually lost this game
today against daro so now they are tied
just a full point behind the the leader
so really a tight group in the a group
this year let's take a look at the B
group um so this is the C group we'll
take a look at that
archers night son's game is still in
action
I think against Brandon Jacobson he is
still leading the group by a half point
of course Demetri Gordievsky is trying
to catch him but we think that Christian
trilha has very very good chances to win
against Gordievsky so that smite spell
at the end of the tournament for archers
Naik songs he might actually just clinch
it here with maybe a drop although I
guess clinch it is is pretty strong to
say but he'll have very very good
chances to to win if Gordievsky doesn't
manage to score a draw in this round
let's take a look at the B group McCrory
oprah is leading by a full point with
five and a half points Sam said via now
is trying to catch him with a strong win
today of putting them back at plus one
overall Monica buzan's game is still
pending so depending on that result
gregorio Oberon might have two chasers
but definitely a good position to be in
coming into these last two rounds with
those standings in mind let's actually
look at some exciting upcoming
broadcasts we have Croatia has actually
already begun so if you're around this
morning you saw round one coverage of
the world's best players in Croatia with
a wonderful commentary team here in st.
Louis guiding you through it it starts
tomorrow or well the broadcast starts
tomorrow morning I believe at 9:30 a.m.
or somewhere around there so if you're
up early
you can have a very very full day of
chess once again after Croatia ends if
the games run long our broadcast will
come on just a half hour after that
broadcast ends or at 3:30 if the games
allow after Croatia we actually have the
US Junior Championship the u.s. girls
junior championship and the u.s. Senior
Championship for the very first time
here in st. Louis those tournaments all
start July 10th keep an eye out for
Brandon Jacobson from the C group of
this event who will be competing in that
US Junior Championship well Jesse any
final thoughts on today's games today's
rounds it's been a beautiful round as
beautiful day for chess I also spent the
morning
looking at the Croatia games and let's
just say these guys are geniuses but
Magnus is at the top and it's looking
like a different level of chess going on
over there
XO stuff we'll look forward to the games
tomorrow all right thank you so much for
joining us
of course my name is Caleb Denby I was
joined by GM Jessie cry and we will see
you tomorrow
with more action from the summer chess
classic this has been a presentation of
the st. Louis chess club
[Music]
you
you